Vor neun Jahren machten sich Beatrice
und Marcel Buholzer auf nach Kreta.
Mit Mitte 50
gibt Marcel nochmals Vollgas
und erfüllt sich
seinen Traum einer eigenen Bar.
Die Gelegenheit,
die ich hier habe, ist einmalig.
Trix geht das etwas zu schnell.
Für dich stimmt es, für mich nicht.
Ich wünschte,
wir hätten mehr Zeit füreinander.
Nur sechs Wochen später
ist die Eröffnung.
Keine Zeit,
aber dafür ein glücklicher Mann.
Jetzt ist es so, wie du wolltest,
was?- Es wird alles gut.
Nach fünf Jahren hat Marcel genug
und verkauft seine Bar.
Es hat schon ein bisschen wehgetan.
Aber heute
ist es mir eigentlich egal.
Beim Wiedersehen
gerate ich ins Staunen:
Sie ziehen in eine riesige Villa.
Das war für uns
ein Sechser im Lotto.
Nur Katze Lisi hat keine Lust,
umzuziehen.
Nein, Lisi, nein.
- Ich sagte es dir: Es geht nicht.
Wir sterben irgendwann hier
und unsere Asche
wird im Meer verstreut.
# Sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
* Möwenschrei *
"Unsere Asche
wird hier im Meer verstreut."
Wie prophetisch dieser Satz ist,
ahnten wir alle nicht.
Marcel Buholzer starb
drei Monate nach meinem Besuch -
mit 66, an einem Herzinfarkt.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Zusammen mit der trauernden Witwe
Trix entschieden wir,
diesen Film trotzdem zu zeigen,
in Gedenken an den Mann,
der den Rock 'n' Roll lebte.
In Kreta hat sich seit
unserem letzten Besuch viel getan.
Marcel verkaufte seine Bar
und Buholzers
wohnen nicht mehr in Agios Nikolaos,
sondern im ruhigeren Sisi.
Und sie ziehen schon wieder um.
Dort ist die Tür.
- Ich habe mich angeschlichen.
Hallo, Mona.
- Trix, das freut mich sehr.
Bitte komm rein. Das ist Carlo.
Ich dachte mir schon, dass das
ein anderer Mann ist.- Zügelmann.
Hier ist er. Marcel.
- Hallo.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
- Bist du gut angekommen?
Sehr gut.
Was macht ihr hier?
Wir warten auf deine Hilfe.
- Okay.
Bereits zum vierten Mal
ziehen sie hier auf Kreta um.
Ich darf gleich
bei Marcels Heiligtum anpacken.
Da drin sind nur T-Shirts.
- Ja, es sind nur T-Shirts.
Von mir ist nichts drin.
Es ist alles von ihm.
* Lachen *
Soll ich das mal raustragen?
- Ja, gern.
Aber nimm die, die ist leichter.
- Wirklich? Okay.
Ja, das ist ...
- Da ist weniger drin.
Die Liebe zum Rock hast du bereits
als Teenie entwickelt, nicht wahr?
Ja, das begann mit 16,
nein, bereits mit 12 oder 13.
Damals waren es noch The Beatles.
Ich wurde mit Led Zeppelin,
Deep Purple etc. gross.
So, weiter geht's nicht.
- Ja.
Wir verstauen seitlich
noch ein paar Dinge.
Was sagte eigentlich deine Familie,
als du als Teenager
nach England abgehauen bist?
Meine Familie
gab es danach plötzlich ...
Für sie gab es mich nicht mehr.
Wirklich?
- Ja, es war ein riesiger Bruch.
Wieso?
- Tja ...
Anfang der 70er-Jahre
musste man in der Schweiz spuren.
Schule, Lehre ...
... RS, ein bisschen leben ...
... heiraten,
Steuern bezahlen und sterben.
Das war nicht mein Leben.
Deshalb haute ich mit 16 ab.
Das führte zu einem riesigen Bruch.
Marcel
blieb sechs Jahre lang in England.
Er war als Roadie
und später als Tontechniker
mit Rockbands wie Led Zeppelin
unterwegs.
Als ich aus England zurückkam
und heiratete,
war ich wieder
ein lieber, braver Schweizer.
Als sie merkten, dass ich
vielleicht in der Schweiz bleibe.
Das blieb etwas mehr als 30 Jahre
so. Nun bin ich wieder weg.
Wir blicken zurück: 2014 wanderten
Trix und Marcel nach Kreta aus
und zogen in eine kleine Mietwohnung
in Elounda.
Er auf der Suche nach einer Bar
und sie mit dem Ziel,
mehr Zeit füreinander zu haben.
Mit dabei:
ihre zwei Katzen Caché und Joy.
* Lachen *
Na, Joy?
- Hast du wieder die beste Aussicht?
* Zufriedenes Seufzen *
Was willst du mehr?
So ist es richtig schön, was?
Ja, es ist wirklich wunderschön.
Komm doch hier rüber. So, ja.
Ein bisschen daneben.
Moment!
Ich schaue nur, ob das,
was wir machten, schlau war.
Ich bin jetzt doch verunsichert.
Ich weiss nicht, ob diese Nägel
wieder wegmüssen oder nicht.
Dann warten wir,
bis du dich entschieden hast.
Auf der anderen Seite war es anders,
oder nicht?
Okay,
du kannst mir die Schnur geben.
(Seufzend) Ach, Mutter ... Ich frage
mich manchmal, was das soll.
Aber ein Mann
muss das nicht verstehen.
Das ist schön fürs Auge.
Das verstehen Männer
wohl wirklich nicht.
Tipptopp. Dann hänge ich
noch kurz Wäsche auf, okay?
Das ist mir egal.
Marcel sollte sich schonen.
Er hatte schon vier Herzinfarkte.
Ich merke es sofort, wenn er
kribbelig wird oder auf 2'000 ist.
Dann sollte man es
etwas ruhiger angehen lassen.
Aber von 2'000 bis auf 180
ist es noch weit.
* Er lacht. *
Du musst immer
das Positive sehen, Hase.
Ja, klar, aber in einem Herzinfarkt
sehe ich nichts Positives.
Das ist das Problem.
Ja, das war negativ,
aber es hatte auch etwas Positives.
Es hat uns die Entscheidung
erleichtert, hierherzukommen.
Trix und Marcel Buholzer
sind sich nicht immer einig,
aber sie haben eine gemeinsame
grosse Liebe: ihre Katzen.
* Pfiff *
Caché!
- Katze Caché ist verschwunden.
* Pfiff *
Um sie wiederzufinden,
sucht Trix Hilfe bei
einer Tiertelepathin aus der Schweiz.
Hallo, Frau Moser,
hier ist Buholzer. Ich bin bereit.
Ich pfeife jeweils nach ihnen. Wenn
sie das hören, kommen sie meistens.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
ob sie verletzt irgendwo liegt
oder eingesperrt ist.
Nein, sie war mal zwei Tage weg,
kam jedoch wieder.
Nun hoffen wir das Beste.
- Auf Wiederhören.
Sie sagt,
sie habe mit Caché gesprochen
und Caché sei sehr, sehr traurig,
dass sie weg sei.
Sie sei weggegangen,
weil wir ständig Streit hätten.
Wir sollten endlich Klartext reden
und die Fakten auf den Tisch legen.
Vielleicht
steht sie dann morgen wieder da.
In letzter Zeit hatten wir
gar keine Zeit, um zu streiten.
Aber wir stritten mehr
als auch schon.
* Mysteriöse Klänge *
Buholzers und ihre Liebe zu Katzen:
Auch neun Jahre später
ist das noch ein grosses Thema.
Ihr habt ja noch etwas
bei mir bestellt.- Genau.
Nein, Trix hat bestellt, nicht wir.
* Lachen *
Also, schau.
Mal sehen, was wir hier haben.
Man kann hier auch welche kaufen,
aber es ist immer dasselbe.
Mit der Zeit können sie es nicht
mehr anschauen.- Wirklich?- Ja.
Aber du verwöhnst sie auch
ein bisschen.- Ja, ja, klar.
Wenn sie das nicht mehr mögen,
heisst es:
"Oh, du Arme, nimm etwas anderes."
Dann stehen
drei bis fünf Näpfe hier,
bis sie eine Futtersorte fressen.
Du willst auch nicht
jeden Tag dasselbe essen.
Es geht nicht um mich,
sondern um die verwöhnten Katzen.
Katzen denken genau gleich wie du.
Die können
nicht so gut denken wie ich.
Zwei Dinge sind geblieben:
Erstens, ihr habt immer noch Katzen.
Daher habe ich
etwa 20 kg Katzenfutter mitgebracht.
Zweitens, ihr streitet
immer noch gern.- Genau.
Was heisst hier streiten?
Das sind
kleine Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Aber wir streiten schon sehr gern.
- Typisch Mann und Frau.
Und schon gibt es
wieder ein Problem mit einer Katze:
Lisi ist Buholzers
vor zwei Jahren zugelaufen.
Du bist ein Schlingel.
Du willst doch mit nach Hause
kommen, nicht wahr?
Wir können sie nicht einfangen.
Es ist ganz schlimm.
Du bist ein Lausemädchen.
Lisl.
Sie muss mit uns umziehen.
Wir können sie nicht hierlassen.
Das ist unmöglich.
Danach versuchen wir es nochmals,
nicht wahr?
Vielleicht kann uns Carlo helfen.
Carlo, Marcels Jugendfreund aus Biel,
ist die letzte Hoffnung.
Alle Versuche, Lisi einzufangen,
schlugen fehl.
Siehst du, was passierte?
Ich hielt sie fest,
aber sie zappelte, stiess sich ab
und weg war sie.
Was hast du vor?
Hä?
- Was hast du vor?
Wenn sie hier durchgeht: zack.
- Ja, und dann?
Wenn du die Schachtel kippst,
ist sie wieder draussen.
Ja!
- Hast du sie?
Hase, sie ist in der Box!
Hol einen Karton.
Wie willst du sie transportieren?
- In der Box.
* Lisi kratzt am Karton. *
Ui!
Lisilein, wir gehen nach Hause.
* Miauen *
Die dreht durch da drin.
- Ja, klar.
Ich kann nicht hinsehen.
Oh, nein, Lisi, nicht!
- Ich sagte es dir: Es geht nicht.
Oh!
- Das kannst du vergessen.
Ja, aber es fehlte nicht viel.
- Die einzige Chance ist ...
Das ist vom gestrigen Futter.
Die einzige Chance
ist die Kiste dort drin.
Ich sagte dir, dass sie sich
gebärden wird wie wild.
Jetzt sehen wir sie
eine Weile nicht mehr.
Diese Katzenfalle
liehen sie sich vom Tierschutz aus.
Beim Umzug
helfen auch ein paar Griechen mit.
Ihre Art zu laden, macht
Schweizer Carlo Kopfzerbrechen.
(Mann) Nur langsam, kein Problem.
Hm ...
Ich würde mich nicht trauen,
so loszufahren.
Das hier könnte rutschen.
* Starten des Motors *
Oh Gott, oh Gott.
Wo stehen wir?
Hat jemand noch den Überblick?
Ich glaube, es ist okay.
- Es ist okay.
Trix benötigt Krücken.
Seit einer missglückten Operation
ist ihr rechtes Bein fast gelähmt.
Ich kann noch nicht Auto fahren
und bin einfach extrem langsam.
Aber nach einem halben Jahr
sagten wir uns:
"Das Thema ist abgeschlossen.
Wir akzeptieren es und leben damit."
So viel zum Thema Streit.
Ich streite nicht nur.
Ich kümmere mich auch um dich.
In guten wie in schlechten Zeiten.
- Also, los geht's.
Ihr neues Zuhause
liegt etwas oberhalb von Sisi.
Du darfst die Tür öffnen.
Das ist es jetzt?
- Ja.
Euer neues Zu...
- Es ist angeschrieben: Aphrodite.
Aphrodite, die griechische Göttin
der Liebe und der Schönheit,
das klingt verheissungsvoll.
Gut, das reicht.
Heute kommt noch der Schreiner.
Hei! Meine Güte, das ist ja ...
... ein Park.
- Ja, das ist ein Park.
Gehört das alles dazu?
- Ja.
Wir fanden nichts Grösseres.
* Er lacht. *
Ich bin ganz überwältigt.
Ja,
es ist ein wunderschönes Anwesen.
Das war für uns
ein Sechser im Lotto.
Aber ihr habt nicht
im Lotto gewonnen?- Nein.
Ein sehr guter Freund von uns
kaufte es.
Er wollte Geld investieren
und sagte,
dass wir uns
nach einem Haus umsehen sollen.
Dann schauen wir es uns an.
- Wir gehen rein.- Ja.
* Trix spricht griechisch
und der Mann antwortet. *
Hallo.
Die erste Katze kommt.
Ist das Joy?
- Ja.
Wo ist denn ihr zweites Ohr?
Sie hatte einen Tumor,
den wir entfernen mussten.
Nicht wahr, Joy?
Soll ich das mal aufs Sofa legen?
Ja, oder vor die Kommode. Ja, ja.
Ich will nicht, dass etwas passiert.
Die Villa ist 340 m2 gross.
Wo hast du das Glas hingestellt?
- Welches Glas?
Ich dachte,
du hättest es runtergestellt.
Du ...
Die beiden haben
noch ein bisschen was vor.
Ein ganzer Fitnesspark.
Was mich an Buholzers neuem Zuhause
besonders beeindruckt,
ist der riesige,
2'000 m2 grosse Garten.
Ich habe mich
immer noch nicht ganz erholt.
Wie ist das für dich,
in ein solches Haus einzuziehen?
Gib es ehrlich zu:
Es ist ein Sechser im Lotto.
Ich war auch vorher zufrieden,
aber das ist ein Knaller.
Wo habt lerntet ihr den Freund
kennen, der das Geld investierte?
Er war ab und zu bei uns in der Bar.
Daraus entwickelte sich
eine ganz schöne Freundschaft.
Nun gehört es eurem Freund
in der Schweiz.- Genau.
Welchen Deal habt ihr mit ihm?
Wir haben einen Zehnjahresvertrag
und kümmern uns ums Haus.
Ich möchte nicht damit beginnen,
ein Bed and Breakfast aufzubauen ...
Das ist euer Ziel?
... und dann in drei, vier Jahren
wieder ausziehen müssen.
Das ist nicht mein Ziel.
Daher
einigten wir uns auf zehn Jahre.
Falls jemand von uns krank wird,
können wir innerhalb
von sechs Monaten ausziehen.
Für ihn war das in Ordnung.
Ich erfuhr es erst, als es abgemacht
war. Ich war auf einer Jeep-Tour.
Als ich nach Hause kam, sagte sie:
"Wir haben einen Zehnjahresvertrag."
Ich sagte: "Na, bravo."
- Ihr wohnt also nicht gratis hier?
Wir bezahlen Miete.
- Ich bin ganz ehrlich:
Wir bezahlen sehr viel.
Ich habe dauernd
den Gedanken im Hinterkopf:
"Hoffentlich geht die Rechnung auf."
Alle drei Zimmer müssen ...
Wir müssen ziemlich ausgebucht sein.
... von Anfang Mai
bis Ende September
die ganze Zeit ausgebucht sein.
Okay. Ein ziemlicher
wirtschaftlicher Druck also.
Ich dachte zuerst,
das sei nun euer Rentnerparadies.
Dann müsste die Rente
aber ziemlich hoch sein.
Ich dachte,
ihr hättet die Bar verkauft
und das Bed and Breakfast aufgelöst,
aber so ist es nicht.
Nein.
- Ihr arbeitet hier weiter.
Wir arbeiten hier weiter.
Mit Mitte 60
wollen Trix und Marcel Buholzer
nichts von einem
ruhigen Rentnerleben wissen.
Sie beginnen nochmals
mit etwas Neuem - einmal mehr.
Wie vor neun Jahren,
als sie auswanderten.
Trix wollte das Leben
auf der griechischen Sonneninsel
gemütlich angehen lassen.
Aber sie machte
die Rechnung ohne Marcel.
Nach kaum zehn Tagen im Land
hatte er seine Bar bereits gefunden.
Juhe.
Ich verspüre
eine grosse innere Freude.
Darauf habe ich sehr lange gewartet.
Nicht wahr, du?
Du bist schon der erste Gast.
Dass Marcel so Gas gibt,
gefällt Trix gar nicht.
Für dich stimmt es, für mich nicht.
Ich wünschte uns mehr Zeit fürein-
ander. Das ist nun nicht der Fall.
Willst du noch Calamares?
- Nein, iss sie selbst.
Und schon gehen sie zum Notar.
- Ganz, ganz viel Geld.
Ganz viel Geld.
Ich packe es gleich wieder weg.
Lange hast du es nicht mehr.
- Eben.
40'000 Euro
kostet der Traum der eigenen Bar.
... three ...
Auf unsere Bar, was?
- Auf die Zukunft.
Genau.
- Und ein Kuss.
* Intro von "Smoke
on the Water" von Deep Purple *
Unglaubliche sechs Wochen
nach der Auswanderung
feiert Marcel bereits die Eröffnung
und erfüllt sich mit der Rock- und
Bluesbar seinen grossen Lebenstraum.
# ... on the water.
(Englisch)
* Jubel, Applaus *
Thank you very much.
Jetzt ist es so, wie du es wolltest,
was?- Alles wird gut.
(Mann) Let's party, man!
Ein Jahr später ziehen Trix und Mar-
cel Buholzer in ein grösseres Haus.
So findet auch Trix ihre Berufung:
Sie vermietet Zimmer mit Frühstück.
Wir kamen hierher, um zu arbeiten.
Da ich nicht mit Marcel
zusammenarbeiten kann,
hat nun jeder sein Ding.
Guten Morgen zusammen.
- Guten Morgen.
Habt ihr gut geschlafen?
- (Beide) Ja.
Wunderbar.
Good evening, Ladies and Gentlemen,
welcome at The Zep.
Die Bar
läuft auch nach der Eröffnung gut.
Marcel hat bis zu vier Angestellte.
Fünf Jahre lang
führt er The Zep mit viel Herzblut.
Gemeinsam besuchen wir nochmals die-
sen Ort, der für ihn so wichtig war.
Vor drei Jahren verkaufte er die Bar.
Ich setzte meinen Traum um
und lebte ihn.
Es lief sehr gut.
Ich kann mich nicht beklagen.
Die vielen Touristen
hatten eine gute Zeit.
Sie wurden mit dem Bus
zu ihrem Hotel gebracht,
stellten ihre Koffer rein
und kamen direkt in die Bar,
ohne sich ihr Zimmer anzuschauen.
Als ich die geschlossene Bar
in dieser Lage sah, sagte ich:
"Was willst du mehr?"
Nur schon diese Aussicht. Man konnte
hier sitzen und aufs Meer blicken.
Abends
kamen die Fischerboote zurück.
Als die Fischer
die Fische ausnahmen,
folgten ihnen unzählige Möwen.
Das war beinahe wie
in "Die Vögel" von Hitchcock.
Das war grausam.
- Und dazu die Musik, die du liebst.
Ja, es war sensationell.
- Ein Guinness und dann ...
Klar. Es waren fünf gute Jahre.
Was war das für ein Moment für dich,
als du merktest, dass es vorbei ist?
Anfangs machte es mir nichts aus.
Aber als ich sah,
dass alles abgerissen wurde
und nichts mehr da ist,
wurmte es mich schon.
Es tat schon ein bisschen weh.
Aber heute
ist es mir eigentlich egal.
Ich habe es gemacht
und nun ist es gut.
Jetzt kommt eine andere Zeit.
Kalimera.
Die Anwohner kennen Marcel alle noch.
(Griechisch)
Das erste Jahr war schlimm für ihn.
Man merkte,
dass die Bar nicht mehr gut läuft.
Marcel war schon sehr enttäuscht,
dass es nicht mehr so war
wie früher.
Er steckte
sein ganzes Herzblut in die Bar
und dem neuen Besitzer war das egal.
Daher war es gut,
dass wir danach nach Sisi zogen.
Machtet ihr euch Gedanken,
wovon ihr leben werdet,
als es um den Verkauf ging?
Damals stand bereits fest, dass wir
das Bed and Breakfast weiterführen.
Und das konnte
das Ganze kompensieren?
Ja, genau.
Na?
- Vespa.- (Lachend) Vespa.
Man wird überall
total herzlich begrüsst.
Ich war kurz in der Apotheke,
um ein Medikament zu holen,
und dort hiess es: "Wie geht's? Wir
sahen euch schon lange nicht mehr."
Dort war plötzlich
so eine kleine Katze.
Ja ...- Dachtest du
schon darüber nach, sie mitzunehmen?
Nein, er hat sie Vespa getauft.
Er vermietet Motorräder.
- Ja.
Das passt, nicht wahr?
Zurück zum Umzug.
Die griechischen Zügelmänner
kommen mit der nächsten Ladung
und schaffen es,
auf dem Weg nichts zu verlieren.
Ist es nicht zu schwer?
- Nein, tipptopp.
Die Villa Aphrodite
hat fünf Schlaf- und Badezimmer.
In drei davon
werden bald Touristen einziehen.
Hier sind die Zimmer,
die ihr vermietet?- Genau.
Das ist das griechische Zimmer.
Wir haben gerade einen Gast, daher
ist das Bett noch nicht gemacht.
Der Gast ist der Umzugshelfer Carlo.
Hier ist ein Bild von einem schönen
Boot. Die Wand strichen wir blau.
Das ist das Bali-Zimmer.
- Ja.
Wow, und hier ist noch
ein eigener Garten.- Genau.
Wie viele Angestellte benötigst du?
Unsere Putzfrau Irma
macht das allein.
Ja.
Ab und zu
wird ein Gärtner kommen müssen -
auf jeden Fall einmal pro Monat.
Marcel muss sich auch um den Garten
und um den Pool kümmern.
Er hat einiges mehr zu tun als zuvor,
aber das traut er sich
trotz seiner Herzprobleme zu.
Der Pumpe geht es jetzt gut.
Ich hatte 2019, bevor wir umzogen,
eine Operation.
Ein Stück der Röhre
wurde entfernt und ersetzt.
Davor konnte ich kaum mehr gehen,
aber nun bin ich wieder
wie ein junges Reh - zumindest fast.
Oder ein Reh mit einem Hinkebein,
ein angeschossenes.
Angelo, on this side.
Es muss auf diese Seite.
Da vorn, in diesem Loch.
- (Lachend) Ah, hier.
Nein, stell es da draussen hin.
Hier ist überall Wäsche.
Stell es nur darauf, Mona.
Ich weiss nicht mal,
wie die Waschmaschine funktioniert.
Das muss ich in den nächsten Tagen
machen. Ich habe so viel Wäsche.
Okay.
Wie beginnen wir hier
wohl am besten?
Am besten mit dem Scheiss dort drin.
Wohin muss es?
- Ich lege alles hier ...
Hier ist noch etwas drin.
Ab hier kann eingeräumt werden.
Warst du schon immer so wagemutig?
- Nein, gar nicht.
Ich bin eher zurückhaltend.
Ich wuchs sehr behütet auf.
Den Wunsch, auszubrechen,
hattest du früher nicht.- Nein.
Das hat eigentlich Marcel ...
Wenn ich ihn nicht kennengelernt
hätte, hätte ich das nicht getan.
Aber so ist es gut.
Es stimmt für uns beide.
Genau das wollten wir.
Du hast dich also
nochmals neu kennengelernt?
Ja, das stimmt.
Ah, hier ist noch mehr. Schau mal.
Gut, dann bringen wir das ...
Du kannst es mir geben.- Danke.
Hoppla.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Seit Marcel seine Bar nicht mehr hat,
hat er etwas anderes gefunden,
um sein Abenteurergen auszuleben.
Zweimal pro Woche
macht er Jeep-Safaris auf der Insel.
Heute hat er
eine Familie aus Deutschland dabei.
Wart ihr schon mal in Griechenland?
Oder wart ihr
überhaupt noch nie hier?
(Mann) Wir sind zum ersten Mal
in Griechenland.- Wirklich?
Ja.- Da habt ihr
die beste Insel erwischt.
* Der Mann lacht. *
Kreta
ist natürlich schon sehr gross.
Von West nach Ost
sind es gut 260 km.
Die Geschichte
geht bis zu den Minoern zurück.
Das waren die Ersten,
die hier waren.
Das war vor 3'000-4'000 Jahren.
(Frau) Viele Olivenbäume.
* Marcel lacht. *
Hier auf der Insel
gibt es ca. 30 Mio. Olivenbäume.
Beim nächsten Urlaub
könnt ihr sie mal zählen.
* Lachen *
* Muntere Bouzouki-Klänge *
Trix hat im neuen Zuhause
viel zu tun.
Trotz ihres lahmen Beins
macht sie so viel wie möglich selbst.
Ich brauche Hilfe.
Ich muss jemanden rufen.
Hilfe zu brauchen und annehmen zu
können, musste Trix zuerst lernen.
Sorry, Carlo,
könntest du mir kurz helfen?
Ich kriege den Abfallsack
nicht aus dem ...
Ah, ja, es entsteht ein Vakuum,
wenn man ihn rausnehmen will.
Ich bin gestresst,
wenn es nicht rasch vorangeht.
Ich erledige
meine Aufgaben eher zackig,
und nun geht es
nicht mehr so schnell.
Jetzt ist alles wie in Griechenland:
siga, siga - schön langsam.
Das geht mir manchmal extrem auf den
Geist - auch noch nach vier Jahren.
Siga, siga?
- Langsam, langsam.
Langsam, langsam?
- Ja, das Motto des Griechen.
Vor vier Jahren
bekam Trix bei einer Operation
eine Narkosespritze in den Rücken.
Sie traf einen Nerv
und lähmte ihr Bein.
Hast du Schmerzen?
- Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Mein Bein ist schwer,
da ich lange auf den Beinen war,
aber einen Hammerschlag aufs Bein
würde ich nicht spüren.
Dafür, dass du dich
nicht mehr gut bewegen kannst,
arbeitest du wahnsinnig viel.
Äh, ja, aber es bleibt
einem auch nichts anderes übrig.
Du könntest auch sagen: "Ich kann
nicht mehr."- Das will ich nicht.
Das wäre uns zu langweilig.
Ich muss schon noch etwas tun.
Es ist ja nur das Bein,
das nicht richtig funktioniert.
Alles andere
funktioniert immer noch gut.
Bist du froh, dass Marcel wegen der
Touren ab und zu aus dem Haus ist?
Äh, ja, sehr sogar.
Wir hocken so oft aufeinander.
Und ihm tut es auch gut.
So, also, da wären wir.
Der Rest ist Fussarbeit.
* Verträumte Klänge *
Marcel führt seine Gruppe zu einem
der ältesten Olivenbäume der Welt.
3'250 Jahre.
Ich glaube, ein Olivenbaum
wächst 0,75 oder 0,5 mm pro Jahr.
Nun kannst du mal rechnen:
Wenn der Umfang pro Jahr
um so viel wächst,
kommst du auf ungefähr 3'250 Jahre.
Das sind Riesendinger.
Hier siehst du,
dass er noch schön grün ist.
Als Beweis:
Hier ist noch eine Olive.
Mit 3'250 Jahren -
das ist unglaublich.
Auf alle Fälle.
- Er produziert weiterhin Oliven.
Ein schönes Bäumchen.
Ich finde das beeindruckend.
Es macht einen nachdenklich.
Als ich zum ersten Mal hierherkam,
dachte ich:
"3'250 Jahre sind unglaublich."
Wie lange leben wir? 60, 70,
80, 90, vielleicht 100 Jahre.
Das, was wir erleben,
ist im Vergleich zu dem,
was dieser Baum alles erlebt,
gesehen und gehört hat,
im Prinzip ein Nichts.
Unter diesem Baum
sassen Dichter und Poeten
und schrieben Gedichte und Romane
oder philosophierten.
Er erlebte bereits
die ersten Minoer.
Das ist unglaublich.
Aber nun sieht er
jährlich zig Touristen.
Über sie würde er wohl
nicht nur Gutes erzählen.
Bei diesem imposanten Baum
kommt eine andere Seite
von Marcel zum Vorschein:
Unter seiner ruppigen Schale
versteckt sich ein zarter Kern.
* Verträumte Klänge *
Trix musste lernen,
Pausen zu machen -
auch wenn es ihr heute wieder viel
besser geht als nach der Operation.
Sie lag vier Monate lang
gelähmt im Bett.
Anfangs fällt man in ein Loch
und denkt:
"Nein, das darf nicht wahr sein."
"Wieso passiert das uns?
Wie haben wir das verdient?"
"Nun hängst du nur im Bett rum,
obwohl du dich bewegen möchtest."
Marcel war mal so genervt -
wir stritten über irgendetwas -,
dass er sagte: "Ich gehe jetzt."
Oh!
- Und weg war er.
Ich wusste schon,
dass er nur etwas trinken geht,
aber als ich so im Bett lag,
dachte ich:
"Was tue ich,
wenn er nicht wiederkommt?"
"Dann bin ich immer noch hier
und kann mich nicht bewegen."
Ich dachte:
"Jetzt muss etwas passieren."
Ich sagte: "Ein Physiotherapeut
muss her. Jetzt wird gearbeitet."
Ja.
Obwohl ich wusste, dass es
nicht seine Art ist, abzuhauen.
Ganz im Gegenteil: Marcel rettet je-
des noch so kleine Lebewesen in Not.
Eine Biene.
In Agios
rettete er alles aus dem Pool.
Auch wenn es nur eine Fliege war.
Und weg ist sie.
Ihr habt schon einiges
zusammen erlebt und durchgemacht.
Du lerntest Marcel
über eine Anzeige kennen.
Genau.- Welchen Typen
stelltest du dir vor?
Ich suchte einen feurigen Italiener,
sportlich, Nichtraucher.
Das Resultat war er.
Besser
hättest du es nicht reffen können.
So ist es.
- Im Nachhinein ... So ist es.
Marcel war bedingungslos für
seine Frau da, als sie ihn brauchte.
Er wechselte meine Windeln,
wischte mir den Hintern ab,
wusch mich,
erledigte sämtliche Einkäufe,
kochte und machte den Haushalt.
Er machte in dieser Zeit
alles selbst.- Ja.
Ich musste mit über 60 lernen,
Windeln zu wechseln.
Das war nicht gerade lustig.
Sogar meine Kinder sagten, dass
sie ihm das nie zugetraut hätten.
Sie wüssten nicht,
ob sie das könnten.
Was sagst du dazu, dass
man dir das nicht zugetraut hätte?
Das wundert mich nicht.
Mir traut man vieles nicht zu.
Was er in dieser Zeit
alles geleistet hat,
rechne ich ihm hoch an.
Das war für ihn
einfach selbstverständlich.
Ich bin halt ein Tausendsassa.
Du bist der Beste, nicht wahr?
- Zumindest fast.
Auch eure ganze Existenz
stand auf dem Spiel.
Wie war das für dich?
Es gab grosse Fragezeichen.
Aber es war eine Beruhigung,
als sie sich zu Hause
wieder einigermassen bewegen konnte.
Da "wusste" bzw. hoffte ich,
dass es noch besser wird.
Ansonsten wäre es
schon brutal gewesen.- Ja.
Wir weinten oft miteinander,
wenn wir nicht mehr weiterwussten.
Aber nun haben wir es geschafft.
Die noch verbleibende Einschränkung
ist eine Kleinigkeit.
Die Stärke der beiden
beeindruckt mich.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch
die Spielkameradin der Katze Joy
für einen glücklichen Neuanfang.
In der alten Wohnung
schnappt die Falle zu.
Leider ist es schon
zum zweiten Mal die falsche Katze,
eine besonders verfressene.
Surprise, surprise.
- Es ist nicht ... Doch.
Nein, die andere ist wieder drin.
* Miauen *
Du bist doch eine Pfeife.
So, hau ab, los!
* Miauen *
Du bist ein Huhn.
* Lachen *
Dann machen wir das halt
morgen oder heute Abend nochmals.
Sie geben die Hoffnung nicht auf,
dass Lisi doch noch zurückkommt.
Die Tourismussaison in Kreta
ist Anfang November vorbei.
So bleibt etwas Zeit,
bevor es im Mai wieder losgeht
und Buholzers
alle Hände voll zu tun haben.
Wie waren die neun Jahre?
Es waren gute neun Jahre -
mit Ausnahmen.
Das würde ich auch sagen.
Das Positive überwog eindeutig.
Was wünschst du dir
für die nächsten zehn Jahre?
Dass es so weitergeht wie bisher,
dass wir ausgebucht sind ...
Gesundheit.
... dass es keine gesundheitlichen
Rückschläge gibt.
Dann sind wir mehr als zufrieden.
Wollt ihr irgendwann
zurück in die Schweiz?
Das ist kein Thema.
Es war nie ein Thema.
Für uns ist ganz klar:
Wir sterben irgendwann hier
und unsere Asche
wird ins Meer gestreut.
Deine nicht, sonst ertrinkt sie.
Sie kann nicht schwimmen.
- Dann kann sie schwimmen.
Das haben wir mal so vereinbart.
Wir müssen ganz klar sagen:
Unser Zuhause ist hier
und nicht mehr in der Schweiz.- Ja.
Ja.- Ich könnte mich
nicht mehr anpassen.
Ihr fandet wirklich
ein neues Zuhause.
Ja.
- Ja, das stimmt. Eindeutig.
Trix und Marcel -
zwei, die ihre Träume leben
und sich durch Schicksalsschläge
nicht entmutigen lassen.
So verabschiedete
ich mich letzten November
von einem zufriedenen
Ehepaar Buholzer.
Und dann Ende Januar
die traurige Nachricht:
Marcel starb an einem Herzinfarkt.
Nach 22 Jahren mit ihrem Mann
ist Trix von einem Tag
auf den anderen allein.
Ich hatte irgendwie noch
nicht wirklich Zeit, um zu trauern.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
wahnsinnig schlimm für mich,
dass es so unerwartet geschah
und er innert 1 Std. starb.
Ich denke,
für ihn war es ein sehr schöner Tod.
Für die Aussenstehenden nicht,
aber das Leben muss weitergehen.
Ich entschied mich, hierzubleiben,
das Ganze weiterzuführen und ...
Ja.
Es muss auch ohne ihn weitergehen.
Marcel hätte auch gewollt,
dass ich weitermache.
Lisi!
* Miauen *
Hm?
Du bist ein Jammermädchen.
Ja, ja, hm?
Die vermisste Lisi
kam doch noch zurück.
Trix will das Bed and Breakfast
zunächst weiterführen.
Zur Unterstützung
hat sie jemanden eingestellt.
Mit Carlo und einem anderen Freund
fährt Trix aufs Meer hinaus,
um Marcel gehen zu lassen -
wie sie es einander versprachen.
Es ist ein seltsamer Moment.
Es ist irgendwie wie ...
... Abschied nehmen.
Ich habe mich mittlerweile
zwar gut daran gewöhnt,
dass ich allein bin,
aber wenn man so viele Jahre
mit jemanden zusammen war,
ist es normal, dass er einem fehlt.
* Rocksong aus Lautsprecher:
"Stop!" von Joe Bonamassa *
# You'd better stop,
# before you tear me all apart.
# before you break my lonely heart.
Ich rechnete nicht damit,
dass das passiert.
Im Oktober
half ich ihnen noch beim Umzug,
wir hatten Spass miteinander
und nun endet es auf diese Weise.
Die Gespräche, die wir führten,
und die Musik aus den 70er-Jahren,
die wir beide liebten.
Insbesondere Led Zeppelin.
- Genau, genau.
Ja.
* Melancholischer Rocksong: "Stairway
to Heaven" von Led Zeppelin *
Mal sehen,
ob wir den Deckel aufkriegen.
# And a new day will dawn
# for those who stand long
# and the forests will echo ...
(Mit brechender Stimme) Bye, bye,
Hase, wir sehen uns wieder.
* "Stairway to Heaven"
läuft weiter. *
# And she's buying
a stairway to heaven.
In der nächsten Folge sind wir
im tiefsten Winter in Kanada.
* Motorbrummen *
Zu Besuch bei Familie Volk.
Vor acht Jahren gründeten sie
hier ein Holzfällerunternehmen.
Die Geschäfte laufen gut -
bis die Krise kommt.
Von diesem Tag an
war das halbe Dorf arbeitslos.
Familie Volk muss sich neu erfinden.
Simone wird Bäuerin.
Hätte man mir das früher gesagt,
hätte ich geantwortet: "Spinnst du?"
# Sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023